a suspect is under arrest in connection
with the murder of a jogger in
Massachusetts more than eight months ago
Vanessa Maher caught a 27 year-old
Google employee was visiting her mother
when she was killed police charged
Angelo colonge Ortiz with aggravated
assault and battery and assault with
intent to rape tony Tecopa is at the
Massachusetts State Police barracks west
of Boston and Millberry Tony good
morning good morning the suspect is
being held here on a ten million dollar
bond over the weekend the Worcester
District Attorney said the actions of an
alert Massachusetts State Trooper and
the victim herself led investigators to
a suspect
she was my other half she is by my
person Caroline Tachi
is Vanessa Moore cause two younger
cousin she loved to run and she loved to
practice yoga anything outside being
with friends and family
Tachi says when Massachusetts police
arrested 31 year old and jello Cologne
Ortiz in connection with marquart's
murder it was a relief we got him the 27
year old was killed last August during
an afternoon jog near her mother's
Princeton Massachusetts home hours after
she disappeared canine dogs found her
naked and burned body in the woods half
a mile away Worcester County District
Attorney Joseph early says Marcotte put
up a fight during her deadly assault
which helped police piece together a
profile of her murderer DNA from a
possible suspect was obtained at a raw
top seat from an examination of her
hands State Police found a match for
that DNA Marcotte was one of three women
killed while running over a nine day
period last summer the other two women
died in Michigan and New York following
the murders runner's world conducted a
female runner safety and harassment poll
42% of women say the only run when it's
light out 71% consider how many other
people will be on their route police
received more than 1300 tips during
marquart's investigation last week a
Massachusetts State Trooper recognized :
Ortiz driving in the same dark SUV
spotted near the crime scene
last August he looked at the driver of
the vehicle and it matched our suspect
not being able to find
piece of paper immediately within his
disposal he wrote the license plate
number down on his hand finding this
person doesn't bring her back but it is
a positive for us and police track
Cologne Ortiz to his Worcester home
where he voluntarily gave police a DNA
sample
he's expected to appear before a judge
tomorrow little is known about him while
police say they believe he worked near
the crime scene they haven't said where
the district attorney meanwhile is
expected to file a murder charge
sometime in the days ahead
Gail such a horrible story really glad
that guys off the streets thank you Tony